This is probably the latest I've ever
been to a review because this is
probably the longest it's ever taken to
actually get the graphics card I need
for the review. Because as you guys
know, Nvidia didn't want independent
reviews with the 5060. They wanted
shills. And it's ironic cuz you guys
call me an Nvidia shill all the time.
Yet, I was blacklisted like everyone
else. And this box is empty just like
the Value.
Now, for those looking for a high-end
custom gaming experience, look no
further than Falcon Northwest. Falcon
Northwest has been building PCs made for
gamers for over 30 years with a focus on
a true high-end gaming experience.
Custom cases available only through
Falcon Northwest feature
state-of-the-art testing and design to
ensure that every component is
performing at their best through thermal
imaging and rigorous lab testing
designed and overseen by the Falcon
Northwest founder himself. With a
complete lineup of systems ranging from
small to large, every Falcon Northwest
system includes a three-year warranty
policy and a year of two-way overnight
shipping coverage providing the ultimate
peace of mind. to see all that Falcon
Northwest has to offer. Follow the
sponsored link in the description below.
So, ironically, ASUS of all people is
the one that came through and was able
to actually get me a 560 card to do a
review on because this is the only MSRP
model that exists for now. All right, so
here we go. About 10 days late to this
review. Ironically, this card came by
way of Canada. I'm assuming that's
to divert away from the things, the
extra costs. Anyway, uh let's talk about
a few things here. Today, I'm going to
be comparing it specifically to the
4060, but you'll be seeing the entire
chart like we do now. Uh so you guys
will see basically this is the battle
for the bottom, if you will. Oh my god.
If you thought 50 Ti was terrible. Um
got to say huge thanks to Acy's for
sending us the card. And also huge
condolences for having to put your name
on it. Can the previous gen, which is
the same process 8 GB crap, compete with
the latest B, you know, bottom of the
chart 8 GB crap, if you will. Okay,
look, I know we're being very, very
salty, but let's face it, this card uh
really is too little, too late for 2025
and future gaming. We know 8 GB cards
are just simply not enough. And there's
a reason why 5060 Ti reviews only came
with 16 GB variants, although there was
an 8 GB card. 8 GB card should never
exist. Anyway, the 4060 is on the 80107
die. Uh it's a 5nm process. It's got
18,900 million or 18.9 billion
transistors. Uh, 1830 MHz base clock,
2460 boost clock. It's got 8 GB of GDDR6
running 128 bit for an effective
bandwidth of 272 GB per second
bandwidth. When it comes to shader
units, 372 CUDA cores, 96 TMUs, 48 ROPs,
24 SM, 96 tensor cores, 24 RT cores.
Now, when we compare it to the next gen,
which is really just a half gen step up,
if you will, it's GB 206. Uh, it's a
Blackwell architecture, obviously. Still
5nm process, but it's got 21,900 million
or 21.9 billion transistors. Uh, it's
got 8 GB of GDDR7 at 128 bit at an
effective
448 GB per second. So, it's pretty much
twice the bandwidth, if you will, as
GDDR6. So, at least it's got that going
for it. Uh but anyway, moving on. When
it comes to the tensor count, uh tensor
cores and all that, it's got 3840 shader
units versus 3072. So quite a big jump
in terms of CUDA corores, 120 TMUs, 48
rocks, the same RO count. Uh 30 SM
versus 24, 120 tensor cores versus 96,
30 RT cores versus 24. So it's kind of
like a little more of everything with
the exception of the memory bandwidth at
that 8 GB capacity though is terrible.
Nearly twice the speed. Um, so when it
comes to specs, really like we've talked
about with 50 series already, cuz it is
essentially on the same process as 40
series was, it's kind of like a half
step, if you will. Now, what I kind of
struggled with how to do this review and
what perspective to take it from, mostly
because I like to do the deep dive now,
or the medium dive, if you will, like
the snorkel dive of power draw and
efficiency and frame times and comparing
them gen over gen over gen. Uh, and it's
it's really I find a lot of people that
are shopping at like the 60 series cards
are not shopping there because they want
to. I feel like a lot of the times
they're shopping there because they have
to. It's kind of what they can afford.
And the 60 uh tier cards from Nvidia are
the entry-level card. So, if you're
putting yourself in the position of the
buyer that is like, I'm going to buy new
and I need to buy affordable, like
that's what you're shoehorned into. you
really and especially with the way
prices are today, you can't even
consider buying or spending more money
than that cuz they start at $300. They
have $299 MSRPs. We'll do some quick
price checking in a second to see if any
of them even land anywhere near that.
Spoiler alert, they get pretty
ridiculous. But when it comes to power
draw and such, the 5060 is a 145 watt
TDP card. It's actually pretty low. In
fact, you only need a 300 watt power
supply as a suggested PSU to run it. So,
I'm just I just kind of didn't do any of
that uh power draw testing and such
because it's so low. It's just not even
really uh it's a moot point. Like, it
really is a moot point. If you can a 300
watt power supply is all that's
recommended or suggested as a PSU for
it, then even your most budget power
supply you can buy today is going to be
able to handle this card. So, it's not
like when we talk about 80 and 90 series
cards where they're such high power
draw, you could run into a problem if
your power supply isn't spec, etc., etc.
So, moving on, let's go ahead and take a
look at the charts. So, when it came to
the charts, I really was only interested
in seeing what the generational uplift
in terms of where they land on the
chart. I didn't even do percentage
figures with this just to see how much
better it is than the 460. So, it's got
a little more of everything. And
obviously, it's got the newest
generation of tensor cores and RT cores,
which are going to give it a little bit
of an edge obviously in those titles
that are using DLSS and um real-time
rate tracing. So, if we look at
Speedway, which is an RT test, uh you
can see we jump up from a 2650 with the
4060 up to a 3488 with the uh 5060
Prime. That's a fairly decent
generational jump, but that's
specifically more or less like testing
the RT generation improvement. And don't
forget, we have more RT cores in that.
But if we look at Time Spy Extreme,
which is obviously a rasterization test,
the 4060 Duel was literally the caboose.
It was the It's the lowest end card on
our chart. It's the lowest scoring card
on card on our chart. and we jump up
from a 4926 up to a 6425. So if Time Spy
Extreme, which is a synthetic benchmark,
was kind of like the only benchmark we
looked at, you could be like, "Hey, huge
generational jump." But when it comes to
games, it's not quite that cut and dry.
So F1 4K, you can see we go from a 21.3
FPS up to a 28.9. So obviously, we
gained about 7 1/2 FPS, which is I guess
if you're down in the 20s, that's
significant. But neither of these cards
should be considering 4K. In fact, I'm
not even going to talk about 4K the rest
of this review with the exception of one
title, and you guys might already know
where we're going with that. But anyway,
if we look at 1440p and F1, uh, we go
from a 47.4 to a 59.9 or essentially 60
FPS. So, it's about 12 1.5 FPS jump.
That's noticeable at that particular
frame rate. We get at least to that
number that's where gamers are are
really trying to land, which is 60 fps.
But if we take a look at 1080p, then we
jump from a 69.3 to an 80.2. So, as you
can see, we technically had a little bit
less of an FPS jump when we went from uh
1080p 4060 to 5060 versus 1440p. So, if
you look at Blackmint Wukon 1440p, we
jumped from a 35.2 with the 4060 up to a
44.3. 1080p, we jump from a 51.2 to a
65.8. So, a fairly good big jump uh when
we talk about going from 4060 to 5060.
And the 5060 is landing right in the
middle, just under the halfway point on
our chart. Um, if we take a look at
Borderlands 3440p, again, the 4060 was
the bottom card on our chart at 61.6 and
we jump up to an 80.5. So, it's actually
a pretty good jump uh when we talk about
Borderlands 1440. 1080p uh from 88.8 to
a
115.7. So, a pretty big jump when it
comes to 1080p as well. Uh, if we take a
look at Avatar Frontiers of Pandora
1440p, we jump from a 43.7 to a 54 even.
And in 1080p, we jump from a 65.4 4 to
an 80.6. So you can see we're getting
we're getting double-digit increases in
performance, which is a nice to have,
but they're kind of brute forcing it,
right? By adding more of all the core
types in there, CUDA cores, tensor
cores, and RT cores. But you would
expect that from a generational
improvement. If we go ahead and look at
Cyberpunk 2077 1440p RT medium preset,
which is still pretty damn hard for
Cyberpunk, we go from a 24.3 in the 4060
up to a 34.4 for the 5060. Uh, so a 10
FPS jump when you're already only
getting 24, that's that's a pretty
significant jump. Uh, if we take a look
at 1080p, we jump from a 42.5 to a 56.6.
So again, at least we have a tangible
improvement there. Let's talk about
Stalker real quick. Um, if we look at
Stalker 1440p, we go from a 37.8 with
the 4060 up to a 47.6. So again, another
10 fps jump uh in 1440p. If we take a
look at 1080p, uh we jump from a 52.9 to
a 63 uh.2. So once again, it's a good
jump, but again, I would expect nothing
more from having uh a new generation of
everything minus the core type
technically. But once again, Stalker in
4K uh is that title that if you don't
have at least 10 GB or more, and to be
even fair, the 3080 at 10 GB has a hard
time running this title in 4K. If you
don't have at least 12 or higher, which
is where we find a lot of the graphics
cards that start to be able to really
sort of push the title, um you're not
playing it. Now, again, it's 4K. These
cards are not intended for 4K. I would
never ever dream of trying to play uh 4K
titles with these particular graphics
cards, but we were getting a whopping
2.2 FPS as our average. Our uh 5% lows
was 1.7, even though you can't really
see it, and our 1% lows are 0.6 FPS. In
fact, it it's so bad that there's about
a three and a half second delay between
when you push a button and something
happens on the game. It's again a an
outlier where it's not a realistic
scenario, but the point is it's a
scenario none nonetheless where we can
find where a card cannot do something.
And my adage for upgrading is it's time
to upgrade if what you have can't do
what you want it to do as fast as you
want it to do it. And I'm sorry, but 2.2
2 FPS in Stalker 4K, of course, uh is
not fast enough. But if we look at the
7600 XT Pulse, which is again a very
low-end graphics card from AMD's 7000
series lineup, it does an
18.7. Why? Because it has more VRAM. And
the 7600 XT Pulse has 16 GB of VRAM. And
that's really the only difference here.
I mean, it's the amount of RAM. Um, and
that was about a $330 card when it was
new. So, obviously more expensive than
these, but it could at least launch the
title in 4K and do something, right?
Again, this is a very specific
cherrypicked test that's designed at
this point. Now, Stalker 4K for us is
more of a VRAMm test than anything else.
But, we got to talk about uh some value
and such. So, again, the card is
$299 MSRP. What I want to do real quick
is I want to kind of do a quick search
and see if we can even find an MSRP
model. Now, the 5060 Prime is the only
MSRP model as far as I could tell by
perusing the websites. Uh, when I was
looking at the retailers and such. Yeah.
So, here we go. Okay. So, looking at
Micros right now, Tustin doesn't have
any in stock, but on the shipable items,
they show GPUs, which is weird cuz you
can't buy GPUs as a shippable item.
Anyway, I digress. The only $299 model
that's shown is a 5060 Prime. Here's
what's funny. Now, if we look at the
other models, models that are in stock
right now at MicroEnter, the Zotac 5060
AMP is 320. So, we're already talking
now a $20 premium, right? The uh Nvidia
560, the Gigabyte low profile is 340.
The R this 5060 gaming overclock from
MSI dual fan is 370. The 5060 Prime
overclocked this card but overclocked
379.
$80 premium for a few extra megahertz
that are already baked into the BIOS.
The MSI uh gaming trio, why the hell
would there be a 5060 gaming trio?
Anyway, I digress. That's a $380 card.
The 5060 tough from ASUS,
$410. And then for $10 more, you can get
a Zotch 560 Ti, which is significantly
faster than a non Ti. So, this is the
madness that we live in that you can
have a $299 card with a $110 premium tax
put on top of it for something that is
not going to actually get you any more
real tangible performance. So, the the
lower tiered cards like this, I never
recommend going with like the crazy OC
expensive models. It's like when when
ACS used to sell the 3060 stricks, which
is a complete waste of money because it
was like a $150 premium over the MSRP.
And those dies are so power limited, you
can't push them very far. So even the OC
models, you're probably only getting
like anywhere between 50 to maybe 75
additional MHz at the most, which is not
going to be noticeable. So this is why
it's just so frustrating that the 5060
uh feels like such a I I can't even
think of an analogy. It's just so
frustrating. I mean, I am gratefully I'm
grateful to ASUS for sending me this
card because no other s uh uh AIBs or
any other brands have really even tried.
I don't think they I I honestly think
that's Nvidia putting their thumb on
everyone saying do not send these cards
for review. And that's one of the
reasons why it might have taken so long
for us to get simply because of the fact
that it's almost like you had to wait
for some of that heat to die down from
all of the blacklisting discussion and
stuff that was going on. But I can tell
you that like hardware unboxed had to go
through some like channels to be able to
get access to a card. Steve at Gamers
Nexus doesn't have a card. Paul's
hardware as far as I could tell didn't
have a card. Linus doesn't have a review
up of the card. I don't have a review up
of the card. I don't see a hardware
kooks review of the card up because the
only reviews you saw online weren't even
reviews. They were previews which was
cherrypicked information that Nvidia
said you were allowed to show. Which is
why once we show this, you can see
compared to other cards on the chart.
Yeah, I I was comparing its uplift to
like 40 60, but if you go back and look
at those charts, and I highly recommend
you go back to that section and sort of
pause on each one and look at the cards
that are neighboring around it, you can
see it's just not a huge benefit to
upgrade from say a higher tier 3070,
3070 Ti to something like a 5060 because
it's just not worth the additional like
these crazy up to $400 cards. It's just
I would I could not imagine spending
more than
$299 on this card. At $299, I don't
personally feel like it's a terrible
value. And I know I might get beat up
for saying that, but it needs to be a 16
GB card. Like, there's no reason this
card can exist at 16 GB and stay at this
price point. I just I don't It's just
greed at this point, as far as I can
tell, because guess what's right around
the corner. This card's relevance is
pretty much already over because in the
first week of June, you are going to see
a card that rhymes with the name of
Schmindy Schmext with 16 GB. It
literally takes this card, well, a curb
stomp is about the only way to put it.
That's all I can say. So, don't run out
and buy a 5060 because you're probably
going to want to run out and buy
something else in a minute.